all right guys
bang bang i've got dave here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
yeah i know thanks for having me here
i'm pumped absolutely let's just jump
right into your background
i feel like you have uh quickly become
the uh the king of new media to some
degree
uh just what did you do before you
started uh all these media sites
uh so i started right out of college i
you know it was like you know kind of
very fresh very fresh i went to
i went to usc film school uh i
i wanted to be a film producer or tv
producer
uh and then got out of school went to
work at
uh endeavour agency uh run by aria
emmanuel
uh and this was like when entourage was
was on and it literally was like that
um you know i was i was lloyd i was
working at a desk you know getting
abused by agents
uh and you know on the side
uh some high school friends and i had
started this sports website
uh and it was just like a total passion
project like hey we
you know we have an idea for a sports
website that we would want to
see in the world uh so we were working
on it and yeah eventually
it kind of got to the point where i was
like well i can you know keep
taking abuse uh you know from from the
agents or
i can go work on this thing on my own
and you know we uh
uh you know we went all in and i i
started bleacher report uh
and i've been you know kind of off off
to the races ever since
you know figuring out as i go along
absolutely where'd the name bleacher
report come from
so that came from uh a brainstorm
uh you know we were trying to figure out
a name and just throwing a bunch of
things out there and like asking our
friends and had some really dumb
like one of the names that uh uh one of
one of the co-founders suggested was
like drinkyourmilk.com
uh so imagine if that could have been it
uh
and then uh my co-founder brian uh you
know
who now now uh runs runs uh bdg
where i'm at um he he was like hey what
about bleacher report and we're like eh
we don't hate it so like we'll keep it
on the list and he said oh well the the
domain's available
i can buy it for 10 bucks so i'll just
i'll just get it so we have it
uh and then uh you know if we come up
with anything better later
you know we'll just have that as in
reserve uh and it's stuck
i love it it's it's always that's how
the naming goes right it's like the the
best of the worst things you can come up
with and then eventually you just make
it into
a thing yeah yeah and our our investors
hated the name they they really tried to
convince us to change the name and they
didn't like they thought it was too long
they thought that they didn't like that
it was like two r's next to each other
it was hard to spell and they tried to
convince us to like hire
this like i don't care how much they
cost but some like
you know naming branding firm to come in
and like give us a new name and this is
like
you know when all the the you know web
2.0 companies had ridiculous names like
zingo and stuff and who figured that's
where it would end up and
we just kind of you know resisted that
that effort and
and uh you know stuck with bleacher
reporting yeah i'd say worked out yeah
it worked out pretty well
uh talk a little bit about kind of when
you guys started this there's
a lot of uh things in media today that
didn't exist or weren't popular
so kind of going and building a website
was uh that was what people did
um talk through like how you finance the
company and just kind of the decisions
you guys made along the way that
uh maybe in uh hindsight given today's
environment people be like oh wait
that's like a weird way to do it but at
the time like that was pretty much
standard how people
financed and grew uh media companies
yeah
yeah so um you know we we
bootstrapped it started out and yeah we
were like you know
college uh you know just recent college
graduates you know i think i was making
like
25 grand a year at endeavor so you know
we weren't like
swimming in savings but you know i've
had some leftover bar mitzvah money and
stuff like that that you know we we put
to work
uh and and uh you know when it was just
a side project
we weren't paying ourselves salary we
didn't have much many expenses we
we outsourced the development to just
like a friend of a friend like we
weren't engineers we had no idea how to
build a website
we outsourced the development to a
friend of a friend who you know ran like
a dev
shop which i'm pretty sure was just like
all you know offshore
uh developers that that he was managing
uh
and they built uh a site on
on an open source uh cms called joomla
uh which might still be around today but
it was like
you know it's pretty like bare bones
basic like there's a lot better
you know options out there today and you
know uh
you know we just didn't know any better
but it served its purpose
you know kind of we probably spent like
a few thousand dollars to like build it
um and that allows us to get it out
there uh and start
building a community building an
audience uh
and then and then we we kind of kept it
going uh
we you know once we quit our jobs uh you
know we got
you know friends and family to to help
out and put some money in
uh you know like i think you know less
than
less than six figures just to like help
help float us
and you know i moved back in with my
parents and and you know we
we had a we got like a small windowless
office that was like
500 bucks a month in the middle of uh
you know the summer in uh
in menlo park uh and so you know very
classic startup type stories and
um you know we kind of used all you know
that friends and family money and that
time to build out
uh you know kind of a custom site and
get off the
the um the open source thing you know we
we uh we hired uh you know a couple
rails developers
uh which you know rails was pretty new
at the time uh
you know to come build like a custom
rails app and launch like
the first real version of a bleacher
report
in maybe six months um and then we went
out and tried to raise money around it
and
you know this was like i remember at the
time like reading
from some of the first articles that
uh the vol was writing on venture hacks
and things like that
and like uh you know it was like super
early days there's no playbook for how
you raise money
as an early founder um there was no like
established community of angel investors
it was all like you know kind of looking
for needles in a haystack
um so it was interesting like we went in
and like pitched some venture firms that
we were like
way too early for but it you know gave
us some like good
reps and like kind of used every every
connection and intro we could get
uh and eventually we found uh these two
kind of super angel investors these guys
who had made
uh just a a ton of money in like the
first
like dot com wave uh and and
you know kind of put together their own
fund to uh fund early stage companies
and
you know they you know bought into our
pitch they believed in what we were
doing and they put
uh uh about a million and a half in uh
and that you know kind of got us started
as a you know as a company but
we stayed super scrappy in those early
years because you know
we were we were young we didn't need
much to survive and
you know we uh you know we're trying to
kind of make it make it last as long as
possible absolutely
and then obviously you guys end up
building you know one of if not the
preeminent
sports site uh in terms of content and
kind of really expand and scale this
thing
uh talk through like you eventually get
to the other end of the journey which is
uh should we sell it or not
uh kind of what was the thought process
there and how did you guys kind of think
through that
yeah yeah i mean we went through this
huge transformation you know it was like
in the early days
you know we got a lot of hate i mean we
probably still get a lot of hate you
know it's just people love to hate
things
uh but you know i remember um you know
there was this like
famous uh segment uh
in the sports media world on uh i think
it's on real
sports on hbo uh in the early days where
like
buzz bissinger was like going just like
crazy over sports blogs and will
leach from dead spin and like talking
about how those guys were like
you know the the worst thing that ever
happened to sports media
um and you know we we watched that and
we were like all right you know we're
part of this like
upstart you know we're gonna like prove
prove like the sports establishment
wrong
but even the sports bloggers hated
bleacher report in the early days and
like will leach
and dead spin i mean they i mean they
were pretty you know they they tore
everyone apart that was the
whole deal but like we got so much hate
we got so much
you know kind of yeah and some of it
rightly so some of the stuff we were
doing was not
you know it was like we had to continue
to raise the quality bar
over time but eventually you know we
kind of
we kept building towards like the vision
that we wanted and like all of a sudden
the tables
started to turn and we you know we the
quality went up
we started to bring in like more of the
sports
media establishment was recognizing what
we were doing
uh we brought out a couple uh executives
uh to join the team who came from like
fox sports
uh brian gray who was phenomenal rich
kalachi who came from cbs sports is our
our chief revenue officer um yeah really
helped to like
put us on the map in terms of legitimacy
like we built this audience we built
this kind of new brand
uh and then we had you know people from
the old guard
you know kind of coming in and you know
things were just
you know at that point taking off and uh
and turner
kind of came in uh you know with with
interested by the company and it
it was like you know it's definitely a
part of
part of it was everything we had built
uh and but
it was also just perfect timing and a
perfect fit
um time warner had had recently
uh spun out time inc uh so timing spun
out as its own
public company um and time warner
you know kind of got got out of that
part of the business um
sports illustrated was part of time inc
that was like the sports
property uh that time warner owned that
they had you know kind of digital rights
to
and all of a sudden they didn't have
that anymore and so they were looking to
kind of fill that
that hole in their portfolio uh and at
the time like the two big
digital sports properties that were out
there were were us
and sb nation um and so they kind you
know
they i'm sure they looked at both uh and
you know our team
you know through some of those execs
that we brought in had really strong
relationships with turner and like we
you know we were just we were growing
like crazy we're profitable
so yeah they came in with a pretty you
know aggressive
offer um and you know we were we just
raised a big
big round of funding from oak uh you
know we were going after kind of a big
like
go after espn strategy uh but you know
it's kind of one of those
offers you can't refuse and um you know
we
decided to you know consider selling the
company and and things just
you know kind of you know led to lead to
fruition from there
absolutely and so as you think of it uh
today like the media landscape has
shifted quite a bit right
and um maybe let's just start with like
if you guys were to rebuild bleacher
reports today
like what do you think is different kind
of like what would you maybe look at
doing differently
than you guys did it was obviously this
this big success
and you go from you know literally you
and your friends kind of just
passion project to eventually this
company that
everyone knows but new environment you
got to take new tactics like what would
be the things that you would do
differently
yeah i mean i think you know the the
you know couple big things that have
been uh you know big developments
in in sports media or just media in
general recently you know obviously the
rise of subscription and paid
subscription has been huge and
um you know i think the athletic was was
early on that
uh and you know a lot of other people
you know
new york times on down have been going
all in on that
um so i could see that you know kind of
as a route
uh and then you know kind of the rise of
the individual creator
you know the uh the pops of the world uh
and so to speak um and you know bleacher
was
part of that obviously bleacher
empowered kind of this whole you know
kind of new
kind of uh generation of sports analysts
um but it was much more like police
reports started as
you know definitely user generated
content it was kind of like
almost anything goes you know too much
goes um and that's that's why we got
some of the hate
uh but you know we kind of started to
like
you know level that up over time i think
you know what would be interesting to
look at would be to look at some kind of
subscription and play you know kind of
looking at like
the best individual creators out there
in sports and kind of bringing them
together on some platform where
um you know maybe some of it's paid some
of it's free
um but you know i think kind of that
that
core piece of like empowering community
empowering people to create
uh you know kind of owning the
relationship you know i wrote wrote
uh you know recently on on my site about
uh how you know police report really
went all in on email
uh newsletters early on and that was
like a huge game changer i think those
those pieces were still there it was
just kind of like
you know some of the tactics have uh
have have evolved over time
yeah and you talked a lot about like
building audiences this idea of like d2c
uh media talk just through like some of
these ideas that you've written about
and
maybe elaborate on like let's start with
just building the audiences today
uh it feels like kind of this
multi-platform you know again direct to
consumer like own that relationship
uh is what everyone's talking about how
do you view that having built one of
these media companies
yeah yeah i mean i think you know it's
one of those things that like you know i
get interesting reactions to some people
are like yeah you know that's obvious
of course you want to build you know
your direct relationship to your
audience and
um you know it's
sometimes you need to say the obvious
things because not everyone
not everyone realizes them or what seems
obvious
isn't isn't as apparent to everyone else
so
you know there's definitely been an era
of
media companies chasing scale at all
costs and
i think yeah that's led to you know some
of the biggest problems
in media and digital media over the last
10 years
and some of what i've been writing about
has been trying to make sense of that
because i
was a part of that as well and you know
looking back
bleacher report a lot of got a lot of
positive press and accolade for
how we built such a large audience such
a scaled audience how we built
on other platforms bleacher has been
dominant on social
for a long time and looking back
i think in in some ways it's been given
credit for
kind of the wrong wrong reasons for its
success and i think you know one of the
keys to success was
owning that audience relationship
through the newsletters and then the
team stream app
and and so you know i think we're going
back to that time where
the the scale at all costs is just it's
it's a strategy that maybe a few people
can play in
if you're if you're really big if you're
really well funded if you're going i
mean
you know where i'm at at bdg media
we have a huge portfolio of brands you
know we're reaching
close to 100 million people a month
we're playing in the scale game but
few can play that game and a lot of
people who've tried have
had just hit a wall but then you see a
lot of other people who focus
on focus on a niche focus on owning the
audience relationship owning that space
thinking about monetizing in different
ways and there's there's so many more
paths
to success there uh you know versus
going to the like
you know go big or both go home strategy
yeah and it feels also
like uh because some of the uh changes
to building the audience that owning the
relationship it's also changed
the funding environment like you don't
see as many companies going out and
raising these really large rounds on the
media side
you've got everyone from uh kind of the
the morning brews on down
um how do you look at that right i mean
there are still
some barstool you know comes to mind and
a few others but it does seem like
there's been this shift
that hey you can build a lot of this
without the venture funding or maybe
venture funding isn't that
the right path for uh for some of these
media companies
yeah i i think it's a chicken into the
egg thing too because
the you know the then i can i can you
know say this from direct experience
with my last company inverse
the venture funding environment for
media just dried up
in the last three four years and
a lot of that was because of the you
know the well-publicized struggles
of these these overly funded digital
media companies
that raised a ton of money and just
couldn't get profitable
you know couldn't grow to live up to
expectations they were being
you know being given uh funding rounds
at
that kind of tech venture valuations but
you know media lives on
on a different spectrum and you know you
look at
the mashable you look at mike.com
uh and you know there's there was just a
lot of kind of well publicized even even
the ones who've done well like no one
knows you know
when buzzfeed is going to have an exit
or
or vox or or bdg where i'm at it's a
it's a
it's an environment that still very much
in question
so that led to
just a drying up of new funded companies
and a new class of bootstrap
companies that were able to figure it
out on their own and become profitable
quickly
and realize that that you can run a
profitable
efficient media business if you aren't
shooting for
100 million uniques and 100 million in
revenue and you might get there over
time but you can do it organically and
you know i i uh early on i met like sam
parr
from the hustle uh and became an advisor
investor to him and he's raised
maybe a million bucks and like they're
doing fantastic
and they've just been incredibly scrappy
and focused on building
the audience uh building different
products that that cater to that
audience and
being really smart and strategic about
it you look at morning brew
you know sounds like they're they're
going to get acquired by by axel
springer for
you know great valuation that's that's
really the way it's done and i think
that's the way it should be done in
media because
you know venture funding for for media
it's not great for the media companies
and not great for the investors
with some exceptions the early investors
of bleacher report are very happy they
invested but
uh you know those those uh kind of
results are few and far between
yeah and i think that now we're starting
to see media companies figure out other
monetization methods as well
right so we talked a little bit it used
to be ad supported now you've got kind
of subscriptions
we're also seeing merchandise we're
seeing all kinds of products like
it just feels like uh when you don't
have that venture funding you have to
focus more on
revenue and profitability what are you
seeing on that front
yeah i think that's the lack of venture
funding and the shift
and you know you have to be you have to
focus on being profitable if you don't
have funding so
publishers are going to experiment more
early on i raised uh i raised money
venture money early for for inverse
largely looking at
following a similar playbook as i did at
bleacher reports so there were certain
things where
i was focused on i need to get to enough
scale to be able to
attract bigger brand advertisers i need
to focus on
growing uniques because that's the
primary metric that
you know uniques and top line revenue
are the primary metrics that
that most investors are going to care
about for me to be able to raise my next
round
what you know what has changed is that
you know with that venture funding going
away
you can you can kind of focus on
different things you know there were
revenue streams i didn't focus on early
on because
i didn't feel like they were going to be
impactful enough to
be able to convince a big a big vc firm
to come in for the next round
so i think that's it's just changed the
whole the whole strategy and the whole
dynamic
and and led to people being a lot more
experimental and really focus on
building building an audience that they
really own and that they can
they can engage with in different ways
because if all you're looking thinking
about is
the you know getting the biggest numbers
possible most those people are not
necessarily going to be
very invested in your brand they're not
going to buy a product that
you develop or sign up for
a paid premium community or anything
like that
and you know they're really just window
dressing to try to help you get
bigger advertising deals yeah in terms
of
um kind of when you see the audience
development now
you were talking about uniques earlier
is that maybe
not as important uh kind of moving
forward and it's more of like
how deep the relationship is with a
smaller number or how do you kind of
think about
some of those metrics whether it's for
investors it's for advertisers
or just understanding the health of
these media businesses right what are
those metrics that you think now
are important absolutely absolutely
uniques
uniques really only matter if you're
trying to sell brand advertising to big
fortune 100 brands they care about that
there are certain brands that won't
won't even take a phone call from you
unless you're at
5 million uniques or 10 million uniques
or that you know the bar keeps going up
and
when you're competing with facebook and
google for some of those deals
it's you can't even be in the same
conversation until you're
you know many tens of millions of
uniques so you know there's it just
it kind of leads to this vicious cycle
where you have to keep growing
to be able to make the money but as you
grow the goal keeps getting pushed
further away
and meanwhile you're not you're not
profitable uh so that's
that's that's a problem and and i think
even in advertising
there's so much facebook and google have
also shown there's so much more
advertising out there beyond those
fortune 100 brands
and they're you know the smaller
advertisers the the direct-to-consumer
product brands they're willing to spend
money with
a lot of different partners they're
willing to test on smaller budgets
and they're willing to scale those up if
they see results so it's it's not
brand advertising it's performance
driven and that's what's driven the
success of
the hustles and the morning brews of the
world and i think yeah it's starting to
seep into just all the publishing in
general
brand advertising is great there's
definitely a place for that
you know it does work uh and there's a
reason that
the the pizza huts and the pepsicos of
the world are
spending tens and hundreds of millions
of dollars on on brand advertising to
you know make sure you remember to buy
their product but there's
there's a lot to be said for this more
direct response performance driven
advertising where you're actually
getting someone to click and buy a
product uh and
in today's world with e-commerce as
big as ever and just taking it taking
over that's just going to become bigger
and bigger so
uh email is such a great medium for that
that's why
email newsletters are going off uh like
no other
right now uh and and uh you know even
even bigger publishers
you know that kind of direct response
type advertising or affiliate
has become big for places like hearst
and
bdg and conde uh so you know it's
definitely
it's kind of changing changing the world
changing the way people think about
things
it feels like a lot of the monetization
was previously pioneered by musicians
celebrities
you know maybe even athletes to some
degree a kind of these individual
creators
um and now the big media companies are
like learning from that right so if you
were a youtube creator
uh and you were getting paid a dollar
two dollars cpms on youtube
and you know 80 percent of your videos
end up getting demonetized anyways like
you just have to come up with other ways
to make money
um and so whether it was merchandise
affiliates like all that kind of stuff
became
uh really popular and very very
profitable for those folks
uh then you give it to a large media
company and say like hey here's the
blueprint
well they just have exponentially large
audiences right and it's almost like
they can kind of
use those uh creators as like r d
for what the large media companies do
does that seem uh
kind of accurate from what you're seeing
yeah yeah definitely
there there was a a big moment when
every publisher was trying to get into
the influencer game
and launch an influencer network or try
to bring in influencers to
partner with on these bigger brand
campaigns which is still very much
a strategy that's alive and well but
it's become kind of table stakes
everyone does it so it's not
really that differentiated i think the
bigger
trend that we're seeing is just these
individual creators becoming their own
media brands
and rivaling the old school traditional
media companies and
you know thinking about it you know hey
if i'm a if i'm a tech advertiser
you know should i be spending my money
on you know an old-school tech site like
like wired or gizmodo or should i just
go with marcus brownlee and and you know
he's got the
the the audience and the engagement and
and
you know there's more authenticity there
so i think that's that's a
a big trend i think it's going to be
interesting to see
how that develops do some of these
individual creators become
media empires in their own right and
you know you think about like martha
stewart media
it's started as one person and you know
now that's a media empire or oprah
uh so are we going to kind of start to
see that develop with these
these digital creators uh where they
they
build out larger horizontal media
companies
or or uh are we going to see either kind
of mergers or like closer
joint ventures tie-ups uh where where
the creators kind of
blend in with the media companies or
media companies get more focused on
building out their own suite of creators
as opposed to really focusing on just
like their top level brand
yeah what are the areas in media right
now that you're spending a lot of time
thinking about or kind of
um you know interested in seeing how it
develops
so i'm yeah i love the the email
newsletter space
i think there's there's a ton of uh
open field there and it's you know if
there's a there's kind of a
debate going on in the world of are
there you know have we reached
peak saturation and newsletters
everyone's got a newsletter everyone's
got a sub stack
uh but the reality is that's in like
the twitter echo chamber and the vast
majority of people are not
uh not feeling like they're over
inundated with newsletters and
probably haven't even heard of the
maybe even the top 10 people on sub
stack let alone the other
thousands of people who are who are
trying to to you know kind of build
there
uh and i think that's that's kind of led
to
just a more similar podcast a more
intimate uh
way to connect with an audience and
build community and i think we're going
to
see
a lot more uh growth and development
and new ideas and new models uh you know
there's
media is very cyclical there's kind of a
tried and true
there's a clear set of media categories
that
that resonate with people that have
existed
since the dawn of time and media uh and
they just continually get like
remixed and remade yeah so you had the
you know the magazine era then the cable
cable tv era then then the
the digital publishing era and now now
we're seeing it with with newsletters
and creators so
uh i think i think that's kind of the
the area that i'm really honed in on is
what's gonna be the inflection point for
newsletters or creators what are the
enabling technologies that are really
gonna
allow them to build their business build
their audience
uh and you know i'm i'm i'm super
curious to see how it all turns out
i have a friend who's got this theory um
this is all great if you can hand
somebody like the playbook
right so like hey here's how you build
these like personal media companies
uh the only problem is that most people
aren't prolific enough
to uh to actually do it how do you think
about that
in terms of the success that
you know the let's say i don't know 500
a thousand people or whatever
are having doing this right now is it
playbook and you can teach that playbook
to just anybody and they should be able
to do this
is it no you've got to have the right
creator and they would have figured it
out with or without the playbook
or maybe is it kind of both like some
people will be really really good and
really big because they know the
playbook and they're prolific
but also that you'll have people who
have a very niche audience
and you know it's only 100 or 500 people
but in that specific you know niche of
the world
they're the thing how do you think about
that
the number one thing in in media and
probably in anything in life is
consistency
it's just showing up day in and day out
even when it's not working even when
you're discouraged
even when you know no one's listening
but but your mom or even maybe even your
mom is
tuned out and that i mean that's you can
have all the town in the world but if
you don't do that
it doesn't matter and that is absolutely
true i
i'd be curious to to hear you know how
you've experienced this is
building your audience and building out
the the podcast it just takes
time it takes months and years of
putting in the reps and
it's it's more about you you will find
the audience that
that you you resonate with whether it's
100 people
or 10 million people and i think that's
that's that's the number one thing and
it's
it was true please report it's true it's
true for the other brands i built
and that you know i think a lot of
people will just they'll
they'll try it out and they'll give up
after a certain amount of time because
it's not for them
or yeah they'll get discouraged or
they'll get hooked into something else
uh but the the people who stick with it
who really find that like clear niche
and let you know the
the the personal monopoly as david
perrell calls it or whatever
whatever you want to call it you find
that that intersection of interests
that you're super passionate about that
there is uh there's demand out there
there's a community that exists out
there
that that wants it but doesn't know it
yet and you'll you deliver it for them
and
that's that's the key in in building any
of these businesses
i can definitely uh confirm that the
consistency is by far
the uh the most important thing and i
actually uh
in some weird way always tell people
it's persistence
because consistency just means like hey
you're doing it every day and that's
actually like
the correct term but this word
persistence is much more like
you've got to do it right like if you're
going to be the creator you've got to be
the persistent one
and that leads to the consistency
um so it's interesting to kind of watch
i think
as uh you know i'm sure you get the same
thing i do
people come in like hey i want to do
this you're like okay here's the
playbook like
go do it for six months yeah two weeks
later like you never hear from him again
right and it's just kind of like that is
probably the number one killer of all of
these is just literally people stop
right and could be for a legitimate
reason family you know some
situation whatever or it could just be
like they didn't see results right away
hey i thought i was supposed to have
thousands of you know readers or
followers or views or whatever
i don't have that it's like it's not
working they just give up it doesn't
make sense yeah
definitely and and look there's there's
there's both a qualitative and a
quantitative reason that you need to put
in that many reps
just by doing it you get better you know
you you recognize
your your flaws or you you you just
develop
a better better better sense better
skill set
uh you have better sensibilities and and
it
takes time and repetition to do that and
then the other part is every
yeah everything you create becomes a
data point
and if you only if you only do it a few
times you do it haphazardly
it's hard to really draw any conclusions
from oh people really liked this one
thing i wrote or this one podcast or
video i created
but they didn't like this one it's hard
to know kind of what the reason is but
if you develop it over time if you do it
enough you start to see patterns and you
start to understand this is how i'm
really
resonating with this audience this is
what they they really really
uh get and and like and and this is what
i can
uniquely deliver to them and you just
need to do that
hundreds of times thousands of times
maybe in order
to get enough a large enough data set to
really
start to make some of those those
observations yeah
it also feels in some weird way uh
a comfort level as well so it's like you
can kind of learn to all stuff but
also it's very um uncomfortable for
people to write or to tweet a lot or to
sit in front of a camera like like
whether you're a tv anchor or you're
literally just on youtube on your webcam
like there is this comfort level and i
think that uh one of the things that
has been fascinating to me is like i can
now see somebody on camera
and immediately tell you whether they've
done it a bunch or not right and you
just kind of pick up on this whole idea
of like
it's one thing to like do an interview
and then it's a whole another thing to
like
sit there with the camera just on you
with no editing
and be entertaining or to be uh to kind
of hold people's attention
and to me like that is the the biggest
argument for just like you gotta do for
a long period of time
because like you're saying like anything
else you just have to improve at it
right
and it just feels like that's kind of a
lost piece of it everyone focuses on
like what am i saying
but if you actually look at like the
best people it's how you say it it's
when you say it it's delivery i mean
like every comedian
right if you go talk to them about like
stand-up comedy they'll say look the
joke is
half what we're saying but it's
everything else that makes it you know
just as funny
and i think that's what kind of creators
and people in these like personal media
companies are learning right now
yeah but you know you hear all the
stories everyone's heard the story about
the
the stand-up comics who did open mics
for years and had no audience and
everything fell flat and they just you
know did the reps over and over again
and they they built their persona and
they built their delivery
and that's the that's the perfect
perfect uh you know kind of story for
this is that you have to do it and i
think a lot of people worry about like
what if i'm not good
you know what if people don't uh like
what i have to say i i
i had those words i still have those
worries when i go and do something like
this and
i just i wrote uh something on my site
about imposter syndrome and dealing with
that and
i think it's something that we all feel
but you think about okay you know
maybe it was jerry seinfeld had uh you
know would bomb for years and years
before he
he achieved success does anyone go back
and and
and dig up those old routines of of
seinfeld's to
to pick them apart no no one cares no
one cares about
the the early mistakes that you make no
one cares about you know that your
your writing or your videos weren't as
polished as they could be
it's just you know it's part of the
process and i think if anything
people respond to that you're
authentically trying to do something and
you have something to say
that you know you're you're you're kind
of building it as you go along
uh just like everyone else and that's
that's a way to to build relationships
and build community
uh and that's that's how the good stuff
happens absolutely
um as you're kind of looking forward
what about audio we haven't talked too
much about that like
how do you see audio and podcast playing
into a lot of this so
yeah i mean audio's something that
i don't i don't have a i don't have an
answer for like i'm still figuring out
i'd love to know your your what you
learned through it uh it's it's
i i would say among the most challenging
mediums to build an audience for
uh at least in my experience i
definitely requires
just putting in tons of reps uh it's
it's a very very saturated space
not unlike what people are saying about
email newsletters but yeah i think
they're at least in my experience i i
know
the playbook for how you build an
audience around email
uh whereas audio i found to be much more
challenging
uh to really break through and i think
you know part of it is
putting in the reps and leveraging
audience that you have elsewhere to to
be able to bring
people onto a podcast i'd love to learn
how
you built yours i know like we've we
have some podcasts
at inverse and input that we launched
earlier this year and they're
i think they're great and they're but
they're you know we have
25 plus million people visiting those
sites every month and
and a lot of people subscribe to our
email newsletters we're still
trying to peel away people by the dozens
to come listen to the podcast and just
get them to
to subscribe and i know like you know
morning brew has
has had similar experiences where
they've got this huge email list and
yeah they've had challenges building out
their podcasts it's just
it's a definitely a long-term thing i
think it's a great medium
uh and either once you have someone
uh that's a super valuable relationship
uh but you know i think
the you know the the growth and and kind
of the
the strategy around it's still still a
little bit of a mystery to me
yeah i am i always go back and forth on
this because it's one of these things
where like when you've got a massive
you know take morning breath got two
million plus people on the email list
uh and when they're like hey
uh the podcast like cross-selling is
really hard
and what i think ends up happening is
like it's
also how hard you push it like for me
because it's my name i can push it
really hard right but hey if you like
what i write
like come listen to this interview right
and and the common denominator there is
a person versus a brand saying like hey
if you like our one product like you
like our other product
right it's a little bit uh different and
so
uh the other hard part is uh it's very
hard to be data driven
because you actually don't know in many
cases how many subscribers you have
exactly all you see is how many
downloads you get right
and so you like it people forget that
it's it's
harder to do this stuff when you don't
have access to the same information that
you're used to
on page views emails you know these
other platforms
um and so definitely uh there's days
where
either we there's tons of downloads or
there's not a lot of downloads and we're
kind of scratching our head like
huh you know why do you think that
happened and you know
everyone starts throwing out their
opinions and you start realizing like
there's no science going on here right
like this is this is complete
estimation or uh guesstimations in terms
of
what's going on uh and you
realize very quickly like hey it's hard
to grow if everyone's just sitting
around guessing all the time
right whereas with email or anything
like you know if you do something
it worked or it didn't work it had the
intended impact or not um and so i think
that that's like a
piece that people who aren't doing audio
forget about a lot
totally totally yeah you don't know the
subscribers you don't know
necessarily how long people are
listening for or
you know what they what they're really
enjoying or not
there's a lot of mystery there and so
you kind of have to fall back on
just keep doing it and keep making it
better
and over time or you know there's
there's people i think the the biggest
success that people have had
it's been leveraging multiple podcasts
or
guests or you know things like that uh
yeah which can be a great strategy
but but yeah it's it's a it's a lot more
of a
anyone's guess type medium absolutely
um what are you doing now uh so i'm
i'm uh at bdg media they acquired
inverse
a little over a year ago so inverse as a
company
i started about five years ago after
selling bleacher report
similar models similar playbook focused
on science and
and innovation and geek culture
and we were acquired by bdg
run by my old co-founder brian goldberg
from bleacher report
they built out a portfolio of brands
starting with bustle
down to the zo report romper elite daily
and they brought in inverse uh along
with mike.com
and uh another brand we launched called
input
to build out this new portfolio brands
uh called the culture and innovation
portfolio so
we focus we're the side of the company
that focuses more on
tech and and culture and and you know
some of these other
other topics uh so i've been building
that out i've been working with uh with
josh dapolsky
uh of uh you know the founder of the
verge and
and uh fame from from tech media uh on
growing that and uh
and continuing to build out inverse
which has just
grown uh tremendously since uh since we
joined the company
that's awesome uh where can people find
you on the internet
so i just launched my own personal site
dave nimitz.com
check it out it's my first uh you know
i've launched
big websites and and done done big
launches as my first
small little personal project in forever
i probably since like the early days of
bleacher report
uh and it was just a way for me to kind
of get
get in touch with this new brand of
creator driven media and
not necessarily throw my hat in the ring
but experience it firsthand and
i've been been writing uh weekly essays
on everything from
uh the the strategies that that we used
at bleacher report to
lessons from the media world to you know
just just general personal essays
uh so so yeah davenimous.com and and
then uh
at david nimitz on twitter it's
fantastic man
and the uh the essays are very good so
please keep writing them because oh
thank you
there's a bunch of people who are
learning from them so uh from a uh
a selfish standpoint uh it's fantastic
that you're doing that
uh i ask everyone the same two questions
as i go to wrap up and you'll get to ask
me one
uh first is what's the most important
book you've ever read
um i i have to say man search for
meaning
victor frankl uh that might i'm sure
that's
that's probably a popular choice uh but
uh definitely had a big impact on me
and and and how i i think about the
world and you know i've been
uh in my my my recent more adult days
uh you know doing a lot of reflection in
the in the quarantine
world and trying to think about you know
how to have the right mindset and right
approach to
everything from raising a family to
pursuing new goals and that's
uh that's a book that just helped me
stay very very centered in
a lot of that i love that answer uh
second question is more fun
aliens believer or non-believer oh
definitely believe her that it's
happening i mean
it's on the 2020 uh bingo card so we've
only got a couple months
left uh i was very pumped when
there was the news like a month or so
ago that they found
possible evidence of of alien life on
venus
the you know the underdog for for uh
for harboring life in the solar system
so i hope you learned more about that
i'm uh i'm planning a cross-country road
trip
uh with my family uh for for later this
year and
roswell new mexico is definitely on the
list of stops
i made sure that so so yeah i'm
i'm i'm all in on on the aliens i hope
they come soon
do uh your kids uh ever ask about the
aliens like do they understand roswell
and kind of uh is there excitement there
are they basically gonna be like dad why
are we
driving so far out of the way uh yeah i
know my five-year-old she'll be very
into it uh she loves
space and astronauts and she's a little
afraid of black holes so
we have to kind of tiptoe around those
uh but i'm sure she will be very pumped
and
and uh we'll probably have to buy a
bunch of
alien memorabilia while we're there i
love it what uh what one question you
have for me to finish up
uh what's what do you see for the the
future of the
the pomp media brand what's what's the
what's the long-term strategy of of what
you've been building where would you
love to take it
products i mean i i think that uh
there's um a ton of
people who and i've talked about it
before like
the joe rogan deal or else you know
other types of deals and they're like oh
you know
i can't believe they did uh that type of
licensing deal
or whatever to me it's like that stuff
is the
small details i don't matter nearly as
much as just like how are you monetizing
right and how you monetize it's
ultimately
a vertically integrated kind of full
stack
uh build and reverse almost this
product company but you do it by first
building out the marketing
and finding the customers and then it
comes much much easier to
actually go and build products that get
product market fit right like
i've always said like the idea that you
build the product and then you go find
the customers
like that's a little uh weird right but
it's been the best way for the longest
time
now the barrier to entry in terms of
building an audience is so low
that you can actually go build the
audience and then figure out the
products right because i think that uh
i think that's you're going to see more
and more of that i don't necessarily
have like
some grand plan but but i just think
like that's an interesting
uh kind of thread to pull on and i think
more more and more people
uh kind of in my position will start
figuring it out um obviously the
really really large creators you know if
you consider kylie jenner kim kardashian
kanye west like
like those folks have done it um but
even look at like a david dobrik right
he's got a mobile app now
uh you look at mr bees things like that
and kind of just again just trickles on
down to
uh the more and more niche you go i
think just more niche products right
yeah no definitely agree love that i
mean i even on the the media
publisher side i knew the the guys at
futurism.com and
you know those guys and they launched
the gravity blanket and
i mean that became the entire business
they ended up selling off the
the media business just to focus on
gravity blanket uh
and of course you're seeing that with
big creators and celebrities and
yeah i think you know you you you build
the community you build the audience you
build the relationship
then you use that as your r d to figure
out what they want how you can serve
them
and i think yeah there's that strategy
works
it works works very very well
listen dave thank you so much for doing
this i think people really uh really
enjoy kind of all the content you're
putting out and obviously you've got
the great experience of building
multiple media brands and in different
environments so uh
i think people will find this super
valuable want to do it again in the
future
thanks paul this was a lot of fun thanks
for having me